over the course of eight seasons of Game
of Thrones to Cersei Lannister managed
to get on the bad side of just about
every other person in Westeros from
complicated schemes to straight-up
ordering someone to kill their own dog
here are the worst things she ever did
and if he not caught up with a show be
warned spoilers ahead to the bitter end
Cersei proved herself a master in
spectacular feats of totally unnecessary
sadism if you have any last words now is
the time way back in season one associa
stablished herself as the cruelest in
the Seven Kingdoms
remember when Cersei son Prince Joffrey
Baratheon gets into a sword fight with
Arya Stark which prompts Arya sped
direwolf no Morea to chomp on his arm
needless to say
Cersei isn't too thrilled about this
realising life could get pretty bad for
no Morea arya sends her away to live in
the woods solid plan but unfortunately
things don't work out quite so well for
Sansa Starks pet wolf lady since she
can't take revenge on the merrier Cersei
demands a lady is killed in her place
and Ned insists on doing the deed
himself most of the terrible things he's
done can be seen as protecting her
family consolidating a power or getting
payback but ordering the execution of a
child's pet because of something another
child's pet did that's just beyond the
pale it might be tempting to blame
Joffrey's felony on Circe's parenting
style which could charitably be
described as indulgent but there's
plenty of evidence to suggest Joffrey's
violent tendencies simply run in the
family
case in point in the first episode of
season 3 a conversation between Cersei
and Tyrion Lannister dredges up a
supremely nasty story from Circe's past
at the age of nine she discovered that
one of her servants had stolen a
necklace and so she ordered guards to
beat the girl they were evidently so
thorough the poor girl lost an eye and
Tyrion reminds her of this fact that
Cersei lights up I remember in a word
harsh Cersei Lannister isn't a
particularly forgiving soul just as the
high Sparrow oh wait you can't you knew
he was in for it once he humiliated
Cersei parading her through the streets
and ringing ashame bell all while
citizens threw things at her shame shame
that was never going to end well in one
of the show's most deliciously vengeful
moments
Cersei regains control of King's Landing
in the most brutal way imaginable
using had an explosive stashed
underground she blows up the great Sept
of Baelor
and everyone who happens to be insider
they putting an end to for ongoing
subplots in one glorious lime-green fire
of course blowing up a 200 year old
church to kill your enemies is generally
frowned upon in polite society and while
she never seemed particularly regretful
about her actions she did suffer one
unforeseen consequence a certain Tommen
Baratheon committed suicide after
witnessing the destruction of the Sept
of Baelor a catastrophe that majorly
killed his wife Margaery Tyrell the
conflict between the Lannisters and the
start of the major focus on Game of
Thrones but the rivalry between the
Lannisters and house Martell it gave us
one of the show's most brutal moments
it begins with Oberyn Martell who's
killed in an epic fight with the
mountain or that both acting as proxies
in a trial by combat needless to say
this doesn't sit well with oberyn's
lover olaria who gets revenge by
poisoning Circe's daughter Marcella not
surprisingly Cersei goes to extreme
lengths to avenge her daughter's death
ilaria and a daughter Tajin as soon
captured and taken to King's Landing
where they suffer a terrible fate
courtesy of 130 Lannister instead of
merely executing them Cersei has a
lawyer and tyene chained up in the
dungeon facing one another then she
poisons tyene with a kiss it's the same
kind of poison ilaria used on marcela
and it takes a very long time to kill
its victims
Cersei leaves a Lhari era life and she
promises that her soldiers will keep her
alive just to ensure she sees every
grisly second of a daughter's death
[Music]
vintage Cersei enough said things start
going downhill for the stark family
would net agreed to become hand of the
king for Robert Baratheon but the breaks
were well and truly off when Robert died
leaving Ned and the kids with no allies
in King's Landing although it probably
goes without saying a Cersei
orchestrated Robert's death that's not
to say she didn't have our reasons my
husband because it felt good to be rid
of him
fair enough well that's another level of
terrible news that it's unfortunate
business
Cersei scheme is just so needlessly
complicated in lieu of far easier
methods like poisoning or beheading
Cersei had to get fancy opting for an
over-the-top assassination plot that
requires multiple steps and multiple
players here's how it all goes down
after seducing her cousin Lancel that
step one says he gets him to deliver far
too much wine to rubber
while he's out hunting hunting what he's
trying to say is rubber got too drunk to
hunt which sounds like the beginning of
some Jeff Foxworthy joke and wound up
getting gored by a wild boar all part of
Circe's masterful plan as Robert dies
the absurdity isn't lost on him King
Robert Baratheon murdered by a pig
that means Cersei relied on three other
living creatures to pull off a scheme
including Robert and a very large pig
and yet a terrible plan somehow totally
worked which only makes it twice as
terrible that's so Cersei check out one
of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about Game of
Thrones are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and to the bail so you
don't miss a single one
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]